claude blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors la visite des manuels macro à
bagdad s'enchaînent donc avec celle au
liban hier
alors d'abord sur la forme ce genre de
mini tournée d'autres présidents n'ont
fait on pense à jacques chirac ou encore
au général de gaulle ce type de visite
très courte
est ce que c'est un impact
oui je crois que c'est très utile parce
que d'une part ça permet de dramatiser
la situation et ça permet en quelques
heures de voir toutes les tous les
personnages qui compte là dans le dans
la ville que l'on que l'on visite
et d'ailleurs cela dit à à beyrouth il
est resté trente six heures ce qui est
beaucoup pour un voyage de ce type
surtout dans un pays qui posent les
graves problèmes de sécurité et en 36
heures il a rencontré tous les
interlocuteurs qui veut les voir y
compris dans la société civile et dans
le fond il a obtenu les résultats qu'il
pouvait obtenir à ce terme c'est à dire
d'abord l'accélération de la nomination
d'un premier ministre
ensuite l'assurance que le gouvernement
serait formé dans les deux semaines que
les réformes structurelles qui
s'imposent bank banque centrale secteur
bancaire télécommunications énergie
gestion du port serait faite dans la
dans la foulée pratiquement c'est à dire
dans les prochaines semaines dans les
prochains mois et en contrepartie il a
indiqué qu' il réunirait à paris une
conférence des donateurs avant la fin du
mois du moins d'octobre
donc je pense que pendant ce temps là
naturellement l'aide humanitaire
continue se poursuit puisque l'urgence
c'est l'aide humanitaire et tout ça se
poursuit alors en ce qui concerne de la
visite à la deuxième visite mais ce
panel visite à bagdad
elle a été très bien préparé puisque
monsieur le drian est venu en visite
préparatoire au mois de juin et madame
par lee est venue il ya exactement huit
jours elle et elle est d'ailleurs allé à
bagdad et adlib hernie bhl c'est à dire
dans la capitale des kurdes et elle a
notamment a indiqué que la lutte contre
le terrorisme n'était pas terminée et
qu'il fallait toujours rester mobilisés
donc le président
a vu tous les interlocuteurs dans la
zone verte c'est-à-dire la zone de haute
sécurité où malgré tout il ya eu
plusieurs attentats depuis plusieurs
années un représentant de l'ensemble des
nations unies et a laissé la vie
monsieur di mino et par conséquent cite
aussi des voyages qui nécessite des
mesures de sécurité tout à fait
particulière alors clos de blanchons on
le disait une visite éclair à bâle à
bagdad quelques heures seulement pendant
lequel lesquels les présidents français
a rencontré donc son homologue irakien
et le premier ministre moustapha al
kazim des entretiens axés sur la
souveraineté alors que comprendre que se
sont dit les chais les deux chefs d'état
écoutent et je crois d'abord que
monsieur mâcon a rappelé l'histoire
récente
c'est à dire que en 2003 la france est
le pays qui s'est opposé au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies à une
résolution qui justifiait une
intervention d'une coalition dirigée par
les états unis et la france y est opposé
avec succès d'ailleurs elle était à
l'époque sur la même position que la
russie et que et que l'allemagne
donc ceci est un rappel par contre
évidemment en 2004 la france a participé
au vote d'une résolution au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui fondait
une intervention contre les djihadistes
les terroristes de l'état islamique et
elle a participé à cette intervention
actuellement la situation évolue puisque
n'est pas de semaine sans que le
président trump annonce un retrait d'un
tiers ou de plus d'aidé du contingent
américain qui est d'environ 5000 hommes
pour sa part le contingent français a
été retiré lorsque l'état major de
l'intervention a été a été déplacée du
de l'irak au koweït et aussi à cause des
problèmes de la pandémie bien sûr la
pandémie qui frappe très durement
layrac alors aujourd'hui il a dit à ses
interlocuteurs que en effet lire app ne
devait pas devenir l'otage de ses deux
alliés qui sont aussi ses protecteurs
d'une certaine manière mais qui sont en
conflit actuellement à savoir les états
unis et l'iran est en effet bagdad a de
très bons rapports avec l'iran puisque
une majorité de la population est chiite
et puis bagdad naturellement compte sur
les états unis pour poursuivre la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamique contre
les résurgences de dèche
d'ailleurs monsieur tram sortent
généralement lorsqu'il annonce une
réduction de ses troupes aux objections
ses généraux qui lui disent mais il y à
une résurgence du terrorisme mais ça
n'est peut-être pas le moment de partir
et d'abandonner le terrain monsieur
mâcon a par ailleurs indiqué que
prochainement il prendrait une
initiative avec l'onu pour renforcer la
souveraineté de l'irak
donc l'idée c'est de faire de l'irak 1 1
point d'équilibré dans la région qui
affirment de plus en plus sa
souveraineté par rapport à son voisinage
et aussi par rapport à l'aller américain
alors en quelques mots pour conclure
claude blanchemaison un autre dossier
délicat qui est celui des jihadistes
français ces anciens combattants de
l'état islamique condamné à mort est ce
que c'est un dossier qui empoisonne les
relations entre les deux pays ou alors
absolument pas vous dire aussi qui est
traitée la doctrine française est clair
monsieur le drian est allé bien souvent
à bagdad pour la répéter la doctrine est
la suivante c'est à dire si un français
s'engage dans les actions terroristes à
l'étranger dans un état tiers
eh bien il doit être jugé par la justice
de cet état tiers dans laquelle il a
commis ces actes terroristes est en
effet on
ressortissants français ont été jugés
par la justice irakienne ont été
condamnés à mort ils sont actuellement
en prison ça pose évidemment un problème
puisque tous les pays européens sans
aucune exception ont aboli la peine de
mort donc en effet monsieur le drian à
plusieurs reprises a suggéré à ses
interlocuteurs irakiens que la peine de
mort soit commuée en détention à
perpétuité
merci beaucoup clos de blanche maison
pour votre éclairage je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales